let's bring in trey gowdy fox news
contributor and host of the trey gowdy
podcast he is also the author of the
book
doesn't hurt to ask using the power of
questions to communicate connect
and persuade congressman thank you so
much for being here really appreciate it
uh my first question is actually more
from a practical standpoint
um how does this work when the president
signs a bill
but then he asks for revision something
that's already been voted on and he's
already signed
what should americans take from this
um that that congress is broken and
those cuts are not going to be
effectuated i mean i i appreciate his
perspective like i did other presidents
that sent
but but he signed it um and those cuts
are not going to be
effectuated in the next couple of weeks
so the only issue is whether or not that
600
is going to go up to 2 000. you know
alicia government is not really nimble
there are plenty of people that have
suffered dramatically this year
and they could use 2 000 or more and
there are some people even though we've
been going through the pandemic have not
been adversely impacted financially so
in a perfect world we would help the
people who really need it
um and and not necessarily help folks
who financially are
okay but but that's not the way
government works um
politically i i really don't understand
what the republicans are doing they're
having this public spat
over two thousand dollars uh per person
uh meanwhile they should be focused on
what happens
in georgia because if if they lose both
the seats in georgia
they ain't going to be any cuts and
there's going to be a whole lot more
spending
well let's talk about the georgia race
there for a second because that does put
um the the two republicans on the ticket
there in a pretty tight spot don't
doesn't it
uh well my advice to anybody in politics
now is just promise more
whatever somebody else is promising just
promise more because i mean that that
that's kind of where we are as a
republic right now i mean this
limited government conservatism um and
people don't subscribe to it so i i
would tell david and kelly
uh whatever the other side's promising
just promised more that's that's
populism that's what we're going through
and that's how you get elected
well let's move on to actually a second
topic now
because you as you know there are two
incoming democratic freshmen
uh into the house who this just
yesterday on the sunday talk show
refused to
throw their support behind nancy pelosi
and her speakership in the next session
take a listen
what i'm going to do is make sure that
the voices of the people are saying
louis are heard
and that we have what we need and so
you'll find out then
you will find out when my vote is
tallied
and again organizing with our community
to figure out what's best
how big of a problem is this really for
speaker pelosi
you know alicia this makes me want to
call my therapist
because the worst votes i cast according
to republicans were for john boehner and
paul ryan
i mean just so your viewers understand
these decisions are made in november
both sides nominate their person for
speaker and nancy pelosi was nominated
by the democrats so
if someone in that caucus wants to be
the speaker he or she should have run in
november
she's the nominee of the democrats and
kevin mccarthy's the nominee of the
republican so
whoever thinks they're going to band
together and prevent her from being
speaker
then her supporters are going to abandon
together and keep whoever you want from
becoming speaker so
it's great theater is interesting
but she's going to be re-elected because
even if she doesn't get it on the first
ballot i mean
who's who's going to get it her
supporters will band together and say
you know what
we'll make sure you don't get it and and
so
she's going to get it it's just a
question of how interesting the vote is
yeah people have underestimated her in
the past and lived to regret it
um how big a problem is this left flank
though for the incoming president
uh it's it's it's terrible i mean i was
listening to bernie sanders early on
today i mean
bernie you lost i don't know if you got
the
the memo but you ran and you lost and
and
joe biden can say he's the most
progressive person
he's a lot more progressive than i want
him to be but he ain't nowhere near
aoc in the squad and bernie sanders so
expectations have been set really high
um if they don't
win the two seats in georgia they're
really not going to be able to
accomplish much
of anything so there'll be
disappointment well it never slows down
trey gowdy it's good to talk to you
thank you so much
yes ma'am you too thank you